so i think we can all agree the rise of
skywalker
was a perfect movie well almost perfect
there was
one teeny tiny little detail that
prevented it from being the masterpiece
we all expected
ray ho
skywalker uh no what else would her last
name be organa
because she trained under leia and had a
special connection with her
come on the obvious answer is naming
herself after the grumpy green milk guy
who ignored her for like a week and then
[Music]
disappeared
the wayfinder's there what's the problem
there a dagger pointing to a very
specific piece of wreckage just floating
there on a turbulent ocean planet it's
almost like you don't understand how
space erosion works need a bit of a
bigger brain there friend
[Music]
okay yeah maybe the renlo kiss was a bit
of a mistake they probably should have
kissed a little bit longer
no the only moment marring what was
otherwise a master stroke of filmmaking
was this
jedi's weapon deserves more respect
yep that's the one that is the one i
can't even keep up the facade that is
the one
and only thing that this movie did wrong
force ghosts are
suddenly too powerful and if they're
able to lift ships and catch lightsabers
then why don't they do anything else in
these movies
why aren't they the ones fighting clone
emperor skin suit over on planet eczema
it's a problem that cinemasins calls out
but i better see an army of jedi ghosts
coming to fight the emperor after this
it's a problem that how it should have
ended calls out
you can use the force and hold the
lightsaber after you're dead
yes heck it's what they list as the way
it should have ended look what i can do
now i don't know why everyone was so
surprised by this revelation
true fans have known that force ghosts
can do anything
just play lego star wars scrubs but all
joking aside the first indication that
we get in the series that force ghosts
can actually interact with the physical
world is
in the original trilogy in return of the
jedi obi-wan shows up as a force ghost
right after yoda's death
and while he's fumbling his way through
retconning the series
why didn't you tell me what i told you
was true from a certain point of view
obi-wan brushes some vines out of his
way
making physical contact with the world
around him
production mistake or critical lore
detail i think we all know what it
really is and i think we all know what
i'm gonna pretend that it is anyway
leave it to darth pad over here to be
the best star wars apologist of all time
because
for all of the complaints leveled
against this new movie and i do think
there are a
lot of valid complaints to be made at
the expense of rise of skywalker i
don't believe that the force coast one
is valid you have to dig deep
real deep but there does seem to be a
reason that force ghosts are unable to
help in these sorts of situations
so just like rey it's time for me to
bring balance to the force she did it by
you know
killing all the evil guys leaving
herself as the only
good force user aka balanced perfectly
balanced
this whole thing should be me on the
other hand i'm gonna do it by
you know trying to invalidate one very
small nitpick in a sea of criticism
using evidence that i'm sure was in no
way ever really intended by anyone
working on these movies
take it away sheeve the dark side of the
force is a pathway to many
abilities some consider to be
unnatural hello internet
welcome to film theory where today
we did it we got ourselves a star wars
theory right
kind of rey is a palpatine just like i
kinda predicted
sure it required the series to bend over
backwards and practically retcon itself
into oblivion but you know what i'll
take a point in the win column
any day i mean we are talking about the
creative team that thought it would be a
good idea to have palpatine's i am still
alive announcement happened in fortnight
so you know what do you expect at this
point
fun fact that brilliant marketing
decision now opens the door for star
wars and marvel
to cross over since thanos and the crew
also spent some time infinity stone
hunting in fortnite so
connected universe confirmed but
seriously why was everyone so surprised
about that reveal at the top of rise of
skywalker as long as you ignore the
entirety of last jedi play fortnite with
the boys and read the canon book series
associated with the new film trilogy
palpatine's return made perfect sense
anyway clearly i'm just trolling i think
whether you liked it or not we can all
agree that rise of skywalker was filled
with a lot of strange storytelling
decisions
a lot of them and as you may or may not
know theory crafting is at its best when
you can try to fill in the logical holes
left behind by sloppy storytelling or
inconsistent world building and at this
point the star wars universe is holier
than
swiss cheese but today i wanted to focus
on one specific issue
force ghosts and how opie they are or
at least how opie they seem like at this
point the franchise we've seen him catch
lightsabers
cast lightning give free therapy
sessions smack people with ghost canes
and lift spaceships out from underwater
they appear on the planets where they
die they appear on the planets where
they don't die
they sometimes don't even appear and
just act as voices i mean they can
really do it all obi-wan wasn't joking
when he said if you strike me down
i shall become more powerful than you
can possibly imagine
literally they are just as if not more
powerful than the actual
living force users walking around the
universe so
if everyone is so concerned about the
rise of the dark side
or the return of the evil emperor or
whatever then why would you ever send
someone living to do the job when you
can just send ghost dad over there
well i believe that there's a very real
in-universe explanation and no
it doesn't have to do with the living
force and the cosmic force and the dead
jedi not wanting to or
not being able to interfere with those
in the living world we'll talk about all
that stuff briefly but that all feels
like a cop-out and honestly i think that
there's a bigger
more obvious and more practical reason
for this one that doesn't require
extensive knowledge of the legends
universe or the animated spin-offs to
comprehend
and that my friends is our theory for
today the first thing i needed to do was
to look into the history of force ghosts
in star wars while there have been a
fair share of non-canonical force
ghosts in the legends or video game
universes the core canon movies make the
claim that qui-gon jinn
invented the technique after his death
or at least he was the first to discover
it in his own time
an old friend has learned the path to
immortality in reality we learn
in the clone wars that qui-gon started
learning this technique through the
teachings of forced priestesses
only to get called away to help trade
negotiations happening over naboo
aka the start of the phantom menace and
that his training is
cut short since by the end of that
mission he dies at the hands of darth
maul
as a result he never truly completed his
training while alive which is why his
body doesn't disappear at the point of
his death
notice how they burn qui-gon's body in
phantom menace whereas obi-wan and yoda
just kind of peace out when they die
show yourself can you i cannot
my training was incomplete as a result
throughout the rest of star wars media
qui-gon is only able to appear as a
force ghost in places that are nexuses
of the force super strong epicenters of
force energy so that's the long answer
for why qui-gon never appears as a force
ghost anywhere else in the series
short answer is that liam neeson was
probably just too expensive for the
cameo after qui-gon's discovery of the
technique
most powerful lightside force users try
to learn it themselves yoda
told i was to learn from you that show
me you could
how to manifest my life after death
who then passes it on to obi-wan in your
solitude on tatooine
training i have for you obi-wan then
spent years studying the technique in
isolation on the deserts of tatooine
anakin skywalker meanwhile just kinda
does a last-minute deathbed conversion
and gets to be a ghost too
must have made obi-wan and yoda feel
real stupid then of course there's luke
who sacrifices himself in last jedi and
not only gains force ghost abilities but
also the hairstyle of a 70s rock band
of course you have force ghost tupac and
finally leia who becomes the final force
ghost of the series until the inevitable
next one at this point the force ghost
plane is far from the special technique
that only the highest level of jedi
accomplished it's now just kind of like
the memorial for cameos past and present
but with so many forest ghosts floating
around
why aren't they actually doing anything
official explanations have been vague
about this the best we have is from the
book from a certain point of view
where we hear what it's like to actually
be a force ghost from qui-gon jinn's
perspective
basically the person's consciousness
passes from the living force
over into the cosmic force where they
suddenly transcend all time and space
they are eternal and in order to
manifest back as a ghost in the physical
realm they have to choose to
for lack of a better term reassemble
themselves in a specific time and
location
the process is described to be kind of
painful and
that's all we get there's been
speculation that
since they're eternal beings who can see
the past and can kinda see the future
they can't interfere with the actions of
the living but that is
so not true i'd say that causing a
lightning strike to burn down an ancient
jedi temple is
interfering just a wee bit or lifting a
ship out of the ocean so the hero can go
fly off to the sith
planet or encouraging a young rebel to
aim his missiles at the very obvious
weak point all of these examples are
absolutely altering the course of events
sometimes in very physical ways so what
gives here what are the force ghosts
allowed and not
allowed to do well here's my theory i
think the answer is tied deeply to what
obi-wan was trying to tell luke as he
left dagobah
the number one lesson in real estate
location location location
the force canonically is stronger in
some places than others even on dagobah
a planet with so much force activity
that emperor palpatine couldn't sense
yoda's presence
yoda can point to a cave that's stronger
in the force than other
areas of the
with planet dark side of the force this
tells us that one the force
is location dependent and two the light
sides and dark sides don't share the
same force sensitivity we see this
imbalance play out the emperor's throne
room in return of the jedi
the emperor and vader both strong dark
side masters have little to no trouble
using their most powerful force
abilities from lightning storms to
vader's ability to use the force to read
luke's mind your thoughts betray you
your feelings for them are strong
meanwhile luke is struggling so much in
this interaction he swings his
lightsaber around like this
[Music]
even his one use of the force in this
battle when he grabs his lightsaber from
the emperor's chair was done in
anger as if luke in this moment had to
channel the dark side in order to access
the force
at all i'm actually going to go even
further than just suggesting that
location is everything and link this to
my ongoing dissection of the science of
star wars and say that
midichlorians are to blame i know we
fans like to ignore midichlorians
because they uh well they kind of suck
but there's some really good reasoning
behind the force midichlorians and their
relationship to force ghosts
as i concluded in an earlier theory
midichlorians are like super hyped
hyped-up mitochondria
that evolved in the star wars galaxy
midichlorians are as qui-gon put it
microscopic life-form that resides
within all living cells
without the midichlorians life could not
exist and we would have no knowledge of
the force which means that more life
leads to more midichlorians and more
midichlorians leads to more force
sensitivity for beings that are made
entirely of the force like a force ghost
this difference would be massive qui-gon
says exactly this
in the clone wars all energy from the
living force
from all things that have ever lived
feeds into the cosmic force
binding everything and communicating to
us through the midichlorians
because of this i can speak to you now
as such
planets with more life should naturally
yield more powerful force ghosts with
more abilities and conversely the
further you get away from the abundance
of life the weaker those force ghosts
and their abilities are gonna be and
wouldn't you know it but that's exactly
what we see play out in these movies
planets like dagobah a huge swamp
and akh2 luke's hideaway in the new
trilogy are teeming with life we're told
that these are epicenters of force
activity and true to form we see force
ghosts in each of those locations able
to be
physically present ghost yoda bonks luke
on the head with his ghost staff he
summons force lightning to burn a tree
ghost luke catches a lightsaber and
lifts a spaceship over on dagobah ghost
obi-wan is able to knock
vines out of his way as he goes to talk
to luke now look at the places where the
ghosts
can't be physically present in this
series when obi-wan says that he can't
help
luke face darth vader in the original
trilogy vader was on bespin
a floating metal platform hovering over
a gas giant planet
other than the inhabitants of the mining
cities the planet was basically lifeless
not a whole lot of midichlorians there
and as such not enough energy for a
force ghost to physically manifest
in a new hope luke is flying around in a
spaceship at the surface of the death
star
no life there and as such obi-wan is
only able to communicate as a voice
in rise of skywalker the sith planet
exigle appears to be made almost
entirely out of barren rocks this guy
is the emperor he has the ability to go
anywhere like his beautiful home planet
of naboo or kanto bite the casino planet
but instead he tends to hang out in big
empty throne rooms even far away from
his own guards he has not taken a chance
that one of these force ghosts is gonna
get a chance to pop out of the blue
teleport in a lightsaber and stab him
but to me the most
telling appearance is in hoth it's easy
to forget but in the empire strikes back
luke actually sees obi-wan as a force
ghost
on hoth and it presents us an
interesting middle ground of these sorts
of appearances
hoth isn't completely devoid of life
like exigal or bespin but it also
isn't teeming with life like dagobah or
octu it's a middle ground
with a middle amount of midichlorians
and true to form obi-wan's force ghost
in this moment
is also in a bit of a middle ground he's
more transparent he's less fully formed
despite snow blowing in the air and
being on the ground his force ghost
isn't physically interacting with any of
that it's a lot like a radio signal with
weak reception it's coming through but
not as strongly as if you were in a
better area
it's exactly what you would expect to
happen if amount of life or
amount of midichlorians were the battery
fueling these sorts of ghost appearances
and for further proof compare
that obi-wan appearance at the top of
the movie to the one that happens later
in that exact same movie on dagobah
here he's fully fleshed out meaning that
this wasn't just like a technical
limitation or creative choice for this
one film so the force ghosts and their
powers in this new trilogy aren't so
much a plot hole as it is just a very
poorly explained mechanic that you
really need to read between the lines in
order to make sense of oh and that you
also
have to selectively choose your evidence
i suppose because there is one plot hole
that even i can't explain
why didn't yoda and obi-wan do something
to vader while he was on
endor we know for a fact that endor is
teeming with enough life to support
stable force ghosts heck we see three of
them hanging out at the ewok celebration
that
closes out return of the jedi mean to
tell me that neither yoda nor obi-wan
felt like helping luke out i mean yoda
had just become a ghost so maybe he was
just getting used to things but obi-wan
really is the worst maybe that's my real
theory today force ghosts can't solve
everything
but they could have at least done
something on endor slackers
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts this is the subscribe
button you're looking for
this is the subscribe button you're
looking for you will press the subscribe
button
you will ring the bell for future
notifications you will help us achieve
the 10 million subscriber milestone so
we could get the glorified paperweight
that comes with it is my force strong
enough
is it coming through the tubes maybe
this is a dark side power i don't know
see you next time